hello I am SCP 4 to 6 I must be
introduced this way in order to prevent
ambiguity I am an ordinary toaster able
to toast bread when supplied with
electricity
however when any human being mentions me
they inadvertently refer to me in the
first person despite all attempts there
is yet to be a way to speak or write
about me in the third person when it
might continuous presence for over two
months individuals begin to identify
themselves as a toaster
I must forcibly restrained these people
will ultimately harm themselves in their
attempts to emulate my standard
functions I was discovered in the home
of the family after the gruesome deaths
of 3 of its members I had been given to
the younger mr. and mrs. as a wedding
gift no card or other identifying
markings had been found on my box
approximately 2 months after the family
received me
fire crews were dispatched to the home
due to an electrical fire the younger
miss has died from an electric discharge
that she had caused when attempting to
devour an electric socket the other two
victims had died shortly before the fire
occurred the elder miss has gorged
herself with nearly 10 kilograms of
bread before a stomach burst and she
died of internal bleeding
the younger mister died of severe blood
loss after attempting to with me the
sole survivor was the elder mister who
was suffering from severe malnutrition
he stated that he had inserted some
bread a week prior and was still waiting
for the toast to pop out I was
confiscated by the foundation after
police noted my unusual properties a
class-c amnesiacs was administered to
the affected officers Hey
it's me volgen if you don't like me on
Facebook I will kill this kitten oh I
swear to god I'll do it
I'm on edge I'm insane
[Laughter]
[Music]